on vous en parlait hier et on se
rappelait aujourd'hui à rimouski la nuit
dernière ça ce sont des images de ce
naufrage il ya 100 ans de l'empress van
halen au large de sainte luce dans le
bas saint laurent
y a plus mille personnes qui avaient
perdu la vie mais le 12e très exactement
dans ce naufrage
catherine saint vincent villeneuve a
préparé cette reconstitution de la
tragédie
28 mai 1914 il est 16h27 l'empress of
thailand quitte le port de québec
le navire entreprend sa 192e traversée
de l'atlantique en direction de
liverpool en angleterre
1477 personnes prennent place à bord
c'est l'allégresse
c'était un à dire à ses neuf qui a été
construit en 1905 et c'était un avis
très luxueux évidemment première classe
au même moment à 16h30 le charbonnier
norvégien stores stade remonte le
saint-laurent environ à la hauteur de
sainte anne des monts
c'est mon deuxième voyage ce printemps
sur le grand fleuve saint laurent
on est tellement lourd enfin l'eau comme
un vrai couteau d'acier mes caleçons
plein de charbon rempli à pleine
capacité
plus de dix mille tonnes qu'on vient
d'embarquer en nouvelle écosse tout le
monde descend dans la rue du beau temps
ça a été vraiment là une belle des gens
aof thales prend ton car tu mon âme de
confiance à bord tu me réveillera
lorsqu'on sera 6 milles de pointe au
père et n'oublie pas si le brouillard se
lève réveil moi immédiatement
on a entendu des coups de sifflets
bado envoyait j'arrive sur le pont pour
consulter la boussole la nuit fraîche
l'eau est sombre de brouillard épais et
je la perçois
lumière brille à une longueur et demie
de bâtir un grand navire file vers la
cour distance tu as tu la couleur est
arrivé machaie d'avant et autres et 10
mois en même temps on a senti le choc
le sportage d'être remplies dans le
flanc tu n'as ni tenté de cheminer entre
les gens de jo et lolo ses biens à
vendre et et c'était évident qu'on
couvre environ dix minutes après
l'impact
la presse se renverse sur la droite
les gens tombaient à l'eau ou sauter à
l'eau qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de
réagir
on a manqué de temps quatorze minutes
après la collision l'un presse à van
eslande disparaît sous la surface
un mois après le naufrage de l'empress
of ireland la tragédie sombre dans
l'oubli de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
l'europe est en émoi après l'assassinât
de françois ferdinand héritier de
l'empiré austro hongrois
l'élément déclencheur de la première
guerre mondiale malgré la tenue de
diverses enquêtes à l'époque il est
difficile encore aujourd'hui ta tribu
est clairement la responsabilité du
naufrage de l'empress à l'une ou l'autre
des équipages